So if yes, it fills are below three is that good news for the patient.
It's, yeah, I'm trying to remember the normal level of yes, it fills the chapel by hand.
So if they're within normal range, that's good news. But again, you could have parasites and not have any imbalance in your.
In your, in your white blood cell code, or any imbalance in your breakdown of white blood cells.
So optimal range of the acidity bill. So, especially if you're talking about an acidity bill percentage, or the absolute via acidity bills, optimal range of the acidity bills 0.03 to 0.2.
If you're talking about the acidity bill percentage. That's a percentage of the total white blood cell count.
That it's 0 to 3 is optimal range. So I think you're talking about percentage.
So if it's below three, it's within normal range, but it still does not in itself rule out the fact that a person could still have parasites.
So again, you don't just, you know, use any type of test and say, oh, this is conclusive that you don't have this or a conclusive that you do have this.
You have to take it and consideration of patients, objective, subjective, fight each other, tests done on history, etc.
Super.